good evening everybody and welcome to
our Seder we want to wish you all a very
happy fourth night of Passover this is a
holiday that celebrates transitions from
confinement to liberation from winter to
spring and aptly it's a holiday that
celebrates tenacity and resilience in
the times of overwhelming adversity now
normally our friends and our loved ones
would gather together on this night and
we'd tell the ancient story and even
though we are all pretty much separated
tonight it seems like this story is more
timely and more important than ever
so we soldier on even though we can't
physically be together we can still eat
and laugh and reflect and dream and we
can do all that while raising
much-needed funds for the CBC Foundation
so please during our Seder locate that
donate button and give it a little click
but first we sing now this is not just a
sit back and relax you actually have to
recline this is a holiday that
celebrates slouching all right so
welcome to our Saturday night Seder
we've got a lot to talk about and give
more to eat take your shoes off a Dakota
there's the bathroom have a seat to
stress may all the stories that you hear
on cable news well it's time to trade
the cable for a table full of Jews
this life is always different from every
other night there's a smidgen of
religion book on keeping that part light
tonight is even stranger than the
average Pesach meal because we're
trapped in our apartments and the
plagues are effin real bang bang
enoughenough celebs all the world's a
bit macaca still we live through tougher
stuff Diana Payne in truth it's been a
lot but PAC goodness let's be grateful
for the good things that we've got
Diane
more is there to say
when you can't go out get drunk so you
need to go out shopping but it's better
not to risk it you some fruit snacks for
corrosive and beef jerky for the Riskin
if you're out of green and table salt
booth don't you fret my dears just lose
a stick of celery to wipe away your
tears the kids only the battery only
thing they learn in home school is their
father sucks at dying tonight the food
symbolic the aged meat spring and all
this wine means I'm an alcoholic
what life is hell yeah
[Music]
so we invited
not to mention every
come to
[Music]
yes yes josh groban everyone the
greatest Jewish voice in Zero Mostel
thank you I'm uh I'm actually I'm
actually not Jewish say what yeah I'm
definitely not either you're kidding
yeah none of us are no way sorry are we
crashing yeah should we go or no no no
are you kidding we're gonna have a lot
of fun where we're raising money for the
CDC foundation so we're gonna have
stories and sketches a lot of laughs and
wisdom idina menzel is going to sing a
demon's ell she alone would be enough
don't you mean yes welcome to our tribe
and we're living in a world we can
hardly recognize what stays constant is
this story and the fact that we'll pull
through so tonight it doesn't matter if
you are or are did you
let's remember we're grateful for who
we're grateful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for those of you who don't know what
Passover is all about congratulations
you skipped Hebrew school let's recap
Ebru school real quick my eighth grade
is really Hebrew teacher Shmuel Nezumi
came back from the break with the new
toupee and we were not allowed to talk
about it Diana Diana Rachel Levin came
back from summer break with sticks and
bandages on her nose not allowed to talk
about it
Diana Magnay knew there is no worse food
less worth waiting for then the food at
a seder I don't know cuz that's a fish
is pretty good if you're a dog yeah hmm
that is terrible one time it's Seder my
cousin Libby pulled me aside in the
kitchen when we were just out of earshot
of my band new boyfriend and she told me
you could do better and then I tried her
tzimmes and I said
so could you I still don't know what
tzimmes is for I think it means
something important Oh Pamela I like you
but I like Jews I like Jews too Julie
Happy Passover everybody watching me
attack wash your hand so here we go now
it was suggested to us that we sing
happy birthday twice while we're washing
our hands but I was thinking maybe I
would do something else so here it goes
I was working in a bridal shop in
Flushing Queens Terrell my boyfriend
kicked me out of one of those crushing
we're with either go what was I to do I
was out on my fanny then I'm gonna
preach and why she did the Sheffield
door I was there to sell makeup but the
putlitz on bought a style a sweat I was
back that's how I became a nanny okay
wasn't that fun now my hands are nice
and clean and we can begin with the
Seder the first Passover was when the
Jews were still in Egypt they were shut
up in their homes they were anxious they
were scared they didn't know the future
and there was blood on the doorposts
this Passover is in a way reminiscent of
the very first different from any that
we have ever celebrated in our lifetimes
but remember what happened labeled the
Passover gave way to deliverance and
that even though it began in darkness
it ended in light
I and a bunch of other people got
together and we ended up doing this
thing called a memory feast so what we
did was we brought all this food and all
of this drink but each thing that we
brought had to be connected to a
specific memory and it was just a great
experience to not only be able to share
that but to feel more connected with
them because they also share its stories
sweet stories of their own backgrounds
in their own childhoods
my younger son reenact the story with
Playmobil characters like the Seder is
so flexible it's such an awesome it's
such an awesome way to have a Jewish
holiday where it's based in the home and
it can be creative and fun with just
kind of a loose structure of you know 15
things you know it's simple we say best
Shana how about the ends meaning next
year the year to come there's a great
song that many of my friends and family
thing when we gather together and the
main chorus goes a tear a or tear a
comma two of you he is a Shauna Shauna
haha meaning we will see we will see
just how good it will be in the year to
come although it may not feel like it
now the song always is a great reminder
that there are so many good things that
are ahead of us if only we can fold up
help
[Music]
have a Passover everyone oh hello it's
the Glazers with the four cups of wine
one I don't think that is not wine is it
it's a cocktail
okay these are these are trying times
okay so this is everyone's favorite part
of the Seder except from mine if the
afikomen happens to be covered in
chocolate this is the part we've all
been training for every night for weeks
drinking but Jews pace your yourself you
know we're not drinkers we have
sensitive tummies mmm
so a long long time ago our
great-great-great what Evers came to
Egypt now you gotta remember this was
before Egypt was Egypt it was like
where's Egypt and there was this fam but
Joseph figured out how to save the
Egyptians Joseph one of our forefathers
yeah brilliant man I'm talking I'm Stein
brilliant big on dreams big on
flamboyant coats and Jesus some people
love them but then he died he died and
then there was this new Pharaoh who
didn't know Joseph you know he didn't
know Joseph from Adam and he looked
around his countries like behold on a
second
all that wait what are all these Jews
doing here yeah and hating Jews wasn't
exclusive then back then this was and
believe it or not wildly original yeah
back then they hate Jews I mean you were
really at the vanguard of culture yeah
so Pharaoh said I hate these Jews let's
enslave them so things changed because a
horrible imagine hearing the most
beautiful song that ever lessons and
being told you're never gonna hear that
song again and what's more you're
forbidden from singing it yourself you
know it exists because you heard it once
should never hear it again this is the
most beautiful song in the world and you
have to live knowing it exists for
others to enjoy but not you
someday I wish upon a star and wake up
where the clouds afford
where troubles melt like lemon drops
oh hey uh above the chimney tops that's
[Music]
at the end of the 19th century a
blistering period of violence known as
the pogroms caused thousands upon
thousands of European Jews to seek
refuge in America embarking on an exodus
of their own millennia after their
departure from Egypt Jews hastily packed
huddled together and crossed an endless
sea in an effort to find a better life
in a land they had only imagined in
lullabies
when all the world is a hopeless jumble
and the raindrops tumble heavy
the magic
[Music]
when all clouds talking up the sky wave
here's a rainbow highway to a place
behind the Sun just a step beyond
to children of those storm-tossed
immigrants Harold Arlen born
hiam arlok to a Lithuanian Cantor and
Yip Harburg born Isadora Hochberg to
Yiddish speaking Russians reach deep
into their immigrant Jewish
consciousness to write an unforgettable
melody set to near prophetic words The
Wizard of Oz opened New Year's Day 1939
less than two months after Kristallnacht
a night that saw Jewish businesses
looted and synagogues burned by the
Nazis here are the lyrics in this
context and suddenly the words are no
longer about wizards and Oz
[Music]
dreams that you dare to dream really do
come true someday I wish upon a star and
wake up where the clouds are far behind
me
where troubles melt like lemon drops
away above the chimney tops that's where
[Music]
hurts fly
oh then why can't I throughout his
career lyricist Harburg continued to
write about justice and liberation not
for just jews but for all oppressed
people
he said the Passover Seder is devoted
entirely to the fight for freedom the
Jews being a minority have always known
that if anyone is enslaved anywhere it
too is their fight their song writing
was beautiful
yes but also urgently political in the
words of composer Arlen music doesn't
argue discuss or choral it simply
breathe the air of freedom
and wake up where the clouds are far
behind me
where troubles melt like lemon drops
away above the chimney tops that's all
the rainbow why then oh why can't I if
every little bluebirds fly beyond the
rainbow
[Music]
[Music]
good evening from Harlem friends and
Happy Passover Imam Ecology and I've
been asked to give some rabbinic
interpretation about the gastro Judaic
mystical meaning of this Passover night
we have this thing called a seder plate
it's a mandala as centerpiece that has
the essential foods of the night each of
them a portal into mysterious meaning
for instance the matzah this bread of
poverty
what slaves ate back in Egypt our memory
of our worst moment but also the first
flavor when we cross the threshold into
freedom economy and slavery the paradox
when you bite into the matzah that's on
the plate we got a big cup because
drinking helps open the heart and be a
little more free you've got this thing I
know what you're thinking horseradish my
whole bitterness you eat this to cry to
physically embody the memories of
oppression and then there's this made it
last night
Kawa set mortar fruit nuts wine cinnamon
delicious but this was the mortar with
which our ancestors built the walls of
their own oppression we've had things
when I say the plate like eggs and
vegetables to eat to remember to unite
into the deeper meaning of liberation
personal and collective in every moment
hey what's up Mike Solomon oh I'm the
chef and co-owner it was a hot
restaurant in Philadelphia and I'm Dan
levy and I can't get a table at Zahav
restaurant in Philadelphia how's your
Passover going good
I've brushed my hair in about two and a
half weeks and it's not bright I'm here
to help you with your seder plate all
right listen we need a bone I've got a
chicken bone here you need something
that resembles a pasta limb um this is a
dog treat I mean it's a bone for my dog
so this is gonna have to do love it hey
do you have something that would
resemble mortar something like Jenny
something sweet I have a pair of butter
that I got in the gift bag that work
that'll work it now you don't have to
read gift it either okay next we need
something that's like lettuce E or
something green I use one name like baby
romaine what is salsa verde do yeah
that's great salsa verde it works you
can have some pickles pickle yes then an
egg we need a roasted egg
okay this used to be a lemon go for it
okay and then you're missing one
vegetable that evokes spring this is off
of a decorative plant that's up all
right you guys to put that down in
between the egg and the salsa verde you
have just completed a seder plate thank
you so much I will set it aside for the
zero guests that will be covered where's
the thinner
don't forget the matzah hey everybody
I'm Andy Cohen and I'm gonna lead you
through what is my favorite part of
Passover and no it is not fighting with
your uncle when he uses the phrase those
people although that's a close second I
mean the afikomen so it is a tradition
to hide a piece of matzah somewhere for
someone to find and tonight that someone
is all of you and you're about to find
out where that somewhere is because it's
time to play a game that we're calling
okay I guess we are really calling up
this find the avi Cohen okay
here's the clue the afikomen is hidden
on a website somewhere on her majesty's
internet www dot
a phrase that has to do with Passover
dot-com okay wow that is really specific
did you get it yet the phrase has to do
with the opening number it's a really
big mystery huge good luck and if you
need me I'll be here in my apartment
like all of us because the whole world
has become literal Real Housewives see
you soon
so I take my favorite thing about being
a Jew is controlling the banks and the
media but besides that I really like
it's a culture of questioning and I like
all the questions that surround this and
and I think the four questions are
probably my favorite part of Passover
and and and usually the youngest and the
family asks those four questions I used
to be the youngest and so I would ask
them but now that I'm no longer the
youngest I thought it would be cool to
bring in my youngest my youngest son to
come in and maybe do the 4 questions
himself hey Nick is going good Finn how
are you son I'm good you got to stop
calling me your son ok can I say that
I'm your co-star in stranger things and
well yeah it won't be true but yeah you
could do that ok great so are you ready
to sing before questions uh I don't
thanks I mean I don't even know the four
questions well I look I don't actually
know them very well myself I just used
to sing you know Hakuna Matata and then
and then my grandfather would cry and
embarrassment so I need to let me help
you Oh piano Oh me oh yeah you're not
the youngest though I can log off kid
[Music]
- Turner Lila has it me call me call her
[Music]
my sheriff or ha lay out on you or fleet
[Music]
[Music]
shut up for Holly look in on my feeling
I feel I love me [ __ ] before Holly load
on your clean finish me to make me sue
be bittersweet
[Music]
you
[Music]
miss you face up everybody that's the
way it's done mic drop
I'm out why is this night different from
every other night great question
Idina it's beautifully asked so matzo
herbs cushions dipping why tonight the
answers are very intense if you're high
so glass tube or excuse yourself to go
bake in the bathroom mmm
the sweet taste of Manischewitz Oh key
nodes of Hawaiian Punch
hello caterer of the later Seder it is I
Joshua Molina with a very early Kol
Nidre appeal on behalf of the CDC
foundation the CDC foundation is as
today's kids like to say that it is a
nonpartisan nonprofit foundation that
does everything it can to fight the
kovat 19 pandemic they provide
protection they provide detection they
provide PPEs and emergency workers so
it's a very worthy cause and I urge you
to dig deep why not give high or twice
high maybe even ten times high Big Shot
why not give till it hurts we're here
trying to raise money for a very good
organization so thanks for taking part
in tonight's seder and give some sadaqa
mother
every year about an hour or two before
the guests arrive for our beautiful
Seder and the smell of delicious
Pesach food wallowing through the house
would embarrass my little brother during
the four questions and make him laugh he
was an deserved it
something about Passover that I often
think about is good filter fish I don't
understand it I don't understand the
smell I don't understand why people
would prefer to eat that in any
circumstance let alone a holiday I would
always hear my mother say this is the
last year I'm doing this every god damn
here I worked so hard and no one
appreciates it
do you understand I'm done so enjoy the
singer this year because it's the last
time I will work like this with no one
no one giving her do you want to stand
oh god I don't even know why I bother
ding dong dancing yeah
[Music]
hi we're back way back way back and each
a planned way back you need your plan
telehealth the Pharaoh has made all the
Jews slaves they are now the victims of
the original pyramid scheme what oh boy
it was a great time to be a Gyptian
welcome to ancient Egypt it's the Year
1400 BC so we are way before Christ but
we are definitely mid party we've got
dancing
we've got great so you've got big huge
leaves to fan you with while you freeze
on a barge
it's like Palm Beach but with less
tennis more clocks we've invented
toothpaste people in Mesopotamia they
haven't even invented teeth yet and here
we are doing all of that with
hieroglyphics that's right hyper hyper
realistic also the Nile isn't just a
river it's a top notch tourist
attraction a perfect place to catch a
sunset or find a baby in a basket but
our biggest claim to fame our pyramids
are great and glorious pyramids
thousands of years from now people will
come from all over the world and they'll
go huh I thought I'd be taller okay
first of all pyramids no we're not doing
that pyramids are canceled we have a
whole her ivory thing that you think
you're gonna be the only shape I don't
think so triangles triangles triangle
you think you invented triangles yeah
why don't you ask Larry Kramer you think
that you think ancient Egypt happened
before the AIDS crisis yes I'm reading
the script
I'm not Jesse Tyler Ferguson I don't
have those chops let's see all day it's
torture the sun shining on me I'll have
melanoma by the time I'm 24 and we all
die in 27 sounds a lot like it oh you
know what the AIDS crisis all right
virtual Seder well my career is going
real
well I know there's like a suburban mom
in Indiana right now watching this with
her 14 year old daughter who loves
Broadway and thinks I'm a little much
well hang in there because in two
minutes you got Henry Winkler and then
at all the okay we need a savior someone
who can help save us we need someone
mighty and brave who will come along and
save us
and fast Thank You Billy you never
disappoint so 5,000 plus years ago the
Jews for without leadership until
finally Moses arrived to liberate them
from slavery and do you know what Moses
said when God found Moses feeding his
goats and asked him to go back to Egypt
to free the slaves Moses said whoa wait
a minute what why me Oh No why me why
would I do such a thing how could you
even think I could do such a thing
Moses didn't feel worthy of the task he
was slow of speech slow of tongue please
Lord ask anybody else but there was a
need to much suffering to ignore too
much work to be done so in a time of
crisis Moses the most unlikely of
leaders stepped up to the plate and you
know what we all have that power every
one of you who is sitting at their
Passover table right now some of you
know you have you paused some of you
have tasted it some of you don't know
it's there you must go on a search for
it because when the time is right when
the need is there you can all step up
through the plate so with a racing heart
Moses goes to Pharaoh with a plea when
my people go
Oh friends so hard they could not stand
let my people go go down my people but
Ferrum would not listen
so the plagues began first the water of
the Nile ran red with blood then Egypt
teamed with frogs and lice and wild
animals livestock fell ill and painful
boys covered everyone's skin so Moses
went to Egypt slain my people my people
go
[Music]
[Applause]
tell old Pharaoh let my people go each
time a new plague began Pharaoh would
promise to liberate the Jews yet no
sooner had the Lord ended the plague
than Pharaoh's heart would Harden and he
would not keep his word
and he did not free the slaves
so the Lord sent a hail of fire a swarm
of locust an endless darkness the worst
darkness where no one could see their
neighbor and finally the tenth plague my
people
[Music]
strike first boom dead let my people go
[Music]
Moses way down in Egypt slave tell old
Pharaoh let my people let my people go
and at last felt release the Jews from
bondage
[Music]
[Applause]
let my people go and that simple phrase
lies the universal truth of Passover
it's no exaggeration to say that the
Exodus story is one of the most
important narratives in the history of
the world forget the fact that it
survived thousands of years this is a
story that if you take into account
Islam and Christianity has deep
meaningful significance for half the
population of the planet and yet it's
allegorical significance transcends the
Abrahamic faiths it transcends Judaism
in fact it transcends religion that's
because all of us no matter who we are
or what God we worship can identify with
the longing to be free from oppression
the feeling of dispossession and exile
the dream of liberation the yearning for
home however it's defined the story of
Exodus is the story of the movement from
oppression to freedom and that's
something everyone of us can connect
with hello everyone temperance here
ready to help out little Sinai
Cinderella if she crosses that Red Sea
and wanders the desert for 40 kids I'm
thinking lightweight and Dabney cotton
based just because you're fleeing does
not mean you can't be dazzling ska
did you see 40 years before Africa I
want to mention one other thing you're
gonna collapse at some point that you
are gonna fall to that desert floor when
you do you're gonna wanna look fab not
drab you do not want to be scab hand
shoes can't shoes are shoes for your
hands you're gonna want to probably go
for like a wedge so that when the elbow
hits it's gonna look so stylized so
elongated so chic
guys we'll put them on my hands and
their handshakes got it but not really
whatever thinking go yeah when you say
forty years that's that's metaphor all
right I think you're gonna be just fine
am I ready gorgeous
my favorite part of Passover is everyone
gathering around to sing some of their
favorite songs my family we did pass
over Broadway parody songs hope you
enjoy a few little tastes into the sea
where our donor has promised that the
land is dry Moses is here and he's the
guy to guide us on our journey or
goodbye goodbye miss Ryan with trying
meet Ryan goodbye we're sick of building
the pyramids losing our firstborn kids
sing meet Rahim goodbye and of course
bang a drum spread the news things are
looking real good for the Jews we've
escaped were alive and now everything's
coming up Moses but of course we can't
forget master of the Jews giving us a
push sure that God is hiding in a
burning bush here another frog there a
little lice thinking Pharaoh's gonna
follow his advice if we do as Moses
tells us all of us will surely lose
heading to disaster following the master
of the Jews to obtain your copy of now
that's what I call Passover donate to
the CBC foundation today all right I
hope you found the afikomen it should
have been a pretty easy hunt as I
literally gave you the answer right it
turns out my sense of fun is not shared
by everybody usually if you find the
afikomen you get money
which means there's a beloved tradition
and every single Passover for all the
children but one to cry and get really
pissed off because they didn't locate a
hidden piece of magic matzah that would
net them a nickel Isaac did you ever
find the afikomen never once Andy and
actually you know what this year I think
it's a better idea
instead of like expecting to get any
money from the
- come on how about giving some money
lending a hand I like it you're
suggesting a little guilt
okay I'm gonna julienne it while we're
at it people why haven't you called your
grandfather thank you and are you
showering have you clicked the leg have
you have you donated to the CDC what are
you doing for Mother's Day and are you
dating anyone because she's gonna want
to know and are you actually dating them
or just like dating them
you miss the guilt don't you you do
right so a good way to alleviate the
guilt is donate the CDC Foundation is
doing everything I can to meet the many
needs that arise during the covet 19
pandemic response protection detection
providing personal protective equipment
deploying emergency staff everything
support them okay and not to guilty or
anything but it's the least you could do
[Music]
at our Passover Seder is we
traditionally describe an all-powerful
God who rescued our ancestors from
slavery but the actual story in the
Bible includes a number of human
characters as well
a pair of midwives who refuse to obey
Pharaoh's order to kill all Israelite
babies and safely deliver baby Moses
Pharaoh's daughter who rescues Moses
knowing full well that he's an Israelite
baby and has the audacity to raise him
in her father's palace breaking his law
right under his nose and Moses himself
who despite his fears and self-doubt
answers the call to rescue his people
this is exactly the kind of courage and
compassion we're seeing right now in
medical professionals grocery workers
and so many others risking their lives
on our behalf this Passover we honor the
stories of our ancestors by honoring the
sacrifices of these heroes
so now standing at the edge of the sea
everywhere you look is water and in the
distance you hear your enemy and they're
making their way towards you you feel a
surge of panic I mean people are saying
you're about to be free what would free
what's ever even mean you don't know you
don't know what to believe in front of
you only the water and behind you the
enemy is closing in all your life you've
never known freedom there has never been
a day when you woke up and your life was
your own this is what's on your mind
does the enemy gets closer and suddenly
the water the water begins to shift
apart like nothing you have ever seen
who knew that there were such things as
miracles on this earth scared to take
each step you fight against your
instincts and you cross somehow
somehow you make it to the other side
terrified everything you were the person
you have been is back there and all you
know right now is that today you
witnessed a miracle and that miracle
sets you free
many nights we pray with no proof anyone
[Music]
we barely understood
[Music]
we know there's much to see we were
moving
[Music]
there can be merry time when
oh ho [ __ ] it's hard
who knows what miracles you
[Music]
somehow away
when you believe
in this time field when we're so often
true
seems like the Samba birds too swiftly
fold away my heart so full I can't
explain seeking faith and speaking there
can be miracles when you believe though
hope is really it's hard
who knows what miracles you can achieve
when you
somehow
[Music]
believe
[Applause]
u.s. and it's easy to give it to your
face by your pain can't see your way
when you be
who knows what miracles you cannot see
sometimes
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
have you passed over everyone stay
healthy and safe holy mother of Pesach
that was gorgeous
I mean holy macaroni that was beautiful
it was so moving it hurts
and it's not just because I've been
staring at my belly button for hours on
end every day the high end okay at this
point your family is rushing through the
Haggadah to get to the food
keep your eye on the prize Jews follow
through that potato kugel is nearly
yours damn fat daya Cove in nineteen
we're on a glickman here urging you all
to include an eleventh plague in you say
to this year click the button to donate
to the CDC Foundation and enjoy your
Passover the only holiday where you are
commanded to drink four glasses of wine
I'm enjoying a beautiful agent I know
should be now may your manicures all
hauled up in quarantine as nicely as -
kiss kiss
well hi everybody this is Senator Chuck
Schumer on Passover night and some have
joked that you can distill the Haggadah
and all Jewish holidays into three
simple sentences they tried to kill us
we survived let's eat
during this Passover with the
coronavirus unfortunately those words
are no joke they are a reality but I
know how many of us feel isolated and
uncertain about the future of
frightening right now but we Jews know
the power of perseverance that's how we
survived over the centuries sticking
together giving each other strength and
moral support and overcoming the worst
the worst of afflictions and persecution
so together we will overcome this plague
like everyone before it so that we can
be happy healthy free once again and we
can have our next Seder maybe not in
Jerusalem but all together with our
family and bread to all of you a decent
Pesach Passover is a journey a journey
within where we pull back the layers of
our soul we look inwards but you realize
from you know this this communal holiday
is that we all are alike doesn't matter
where you're from what you do how much
you know rituals may change the language
and methods of observance may change but
their beliefs in what we share and what
we hold dear to one another our families
are annoying relatives who want to
constantly question who is our love life
and who isn't
we're all the same we're all connected
each and every one of us is holy is
connected to our banner ultimately Jews
are just people
to get together just sit and sullen
silence just waiting for someone to
finish talking so I can get some food in
their faces and through that together to
experiencing that unity those
individuals will experience it as a
people as a world and we wouldn't reach
every one of us in our lives
Happy Passover I'm taken back to a story
that is thousands of years old this
story that we told tonight a story
that's held a grip on the human
imagination for thousands of years
precisely because it was never just
about what happened then but has also
always been about what's happening now
it's never been just about what happened
to them but it's always been about
what's also happening to us this is a
story of an Israelite people who were
degraded and oppressed and enslaved and
then somehow through the series of
miracles both divine and human were able
to begin to walk on that long journey
toward freedom this is a story in the
language of our rabbis may feel a delay
or out of a trajectory that takes us
from darkness to light may agon lisinga
from anguish to joy from grief to
celebration from narrowness to great
expansiveness from degradation to
dignity and our rabbis understood that
that was a message that we needed to
hear not only once but needed to be
built into our DNA so that we would have
the muscle memory for hope exactly in
moments like the ones we're living in
right now when we need hope the most in
fact this story is the closest thing we
have to the genetic transmission of Hope
because it tells us that even though
things are painful and hard and we are
incredibly vulnerable right now that we
will survive this that our story doesn't
end here
and that we like those who came before
us will one day come to the other side
of this plague of darkness and when we
do we will grieve and then we will
rebuild and I pray on this night that we
will do what the Israelites did so many
years ago they rebuilt a society that
was the counter Egypt that was the
antithesis of what they had experienced
in their suffering in Egypt and we will
build a society that is counter to the
in justices and impressions and
indignities of this world that we have
lived in and instead will build a world
rooted in justice and equity and
equality and dignity for all people and
most of all in love and that will be a
beautiful world for all of us hey we
can't thank you enough for joining us
and with that our Passover Seder is
about to come actually hi I'm sorry I
have a couple questions yes Josh grobin
everyone the best non-jewish voice since
Bobby there thank you yeah this has been
so great thank you so much for having me
but I was wondering um where's Cod Gallo
yeah HOD god yeah I was wondering about
that as well who told you guys about
shotgun yeah dude come on we all know
about God God ya know it's rockin I
think it every time I play tel-aviv very
good guys AB so you see what about the
what about the leading can we talk about
all that the leaning where'd that go
yeah you know the four sons the matzo
sandwich come on and you're seriously
not gonna open the door for Elijah how
do you guys know so much about Passover
Debian high school no way I wish I was
to be in high school - that's amazing
and I love mrs. Mason take a wild guess
so how about the afikomen well we're not
opening the doors for strangers right
now Rachel but but when you're right
you're right yes let's find out who
found the afikomen what be actual
oh my god
oh my god I found the afikomen I found
the optic almond it was inside my oh my
gosh I knew it was inside me the whole
time
[Music]
hi everybody happy Pesach it's me
Elijah I'm so happy to see you were you
expecting somebody else
Amman yeah that happens to me a lot
please nobody but me could pull off a
schedule like this now for those of you
out there who don't know me I'm kind of
like a Santa Claus but my people believe
me glasses of wine instead of cookies
and milk and my only gift is him is with
them I do want to say though to all my
friends out there who've been so kind
over thee is plying me with wine and
more and her OSIS and all that I I've
been sober for about 300 years so a next
year a few Panola bars would be just
fine well anyway I just want to say I
know you might be having a tough time
out there or all by yourselves maybe
going a little bit stir-crazy yes very
scary but listen I have to visit two
million homes a night and that is very
very scary too and it's not good social
distancing so so stay in just wanna stay
stay in watch your hands be kind be good
to each other mostly be good to meet you
you know I said
next year in Jerusalem as a kid those
are always my favorite words at the
Seder because they meant it was almost
over and time for dessert macaroons
pineapple slices and a noodle pudding
topped with candied cherries as I grew
into the age of knowing that all I began
to question next year in Jerusalem I
mean why would anyone want to go to
Jerusalem it's hot you're surrounded by
a vast majority of anti-semites and all
the king's soldiers in uniform our girls
made no sense to me that Jews would want
to go to Israel I know it has Sam you
can pick up a foot mahjong game but
Miami it ain't still after everything
Jews went through the Holocaust when
asked where they wanted to make their
homeland they pit Jerusalem you are
proof that it's a bad idea
Jared Kushner thinks it's a good idea I
rest my case
if it was me I would have said due to
the Germans and take a Berlin can you
imagine Berlin is the Jewish homeland
beautiful architecture museums and
centrally located to all the other
wonderful European cities what's
Jerusalem near the Dead Sea that's like
people that spending their life savings
to go to Las Vegas and staying at the
Luxor Hotel gee honey where should we go
on vacation I know
let's go stay in a big black pool and so
I spend my years of enlightenment
shaking my head whenever my father read
out those words next year in Jerusalem
so now I'm old and with age comes
irritable bowels and wisdom unless of
course you're a white Christian
heterosexual man in flyover country and
instead of wisdom you get gas and
scratch-off tickets
I now realize that all of religion can
be taken with a grain of salt and
adapted to whatever belief system to
which you wish to subscribe
and so that phrase has no meaning to me
next year in Jerusalem to me means next
year we will be in our home and that
home will be a world without fear a
world without hunger a world without
poverty and rot next year we will be in
a world that is caring and supportive of
its inhabitants and a world where its
inhabitants are caring and supportive of
the world in which they live next year
we will look to our great minds for
leadership and ask you loudmouth fools
next year we will remember the lessons
of kindness from our youth next year we
will aspire to live our possibilities
next year we will be grateful for the
gift of life we've been given next year
we will achieve our goals and share our
bounty with family friends and neighbors
next year the word stranger will be
meaningless because next year we will
all be together in our home so next year
in Jerusalem now serve the sponge cake
when the walls have rolled narrow
well the world tester ray
and the headlines are hailing day after
day
as you wonder and wonder how long you'll
stay lost and worthy oceans and deserts
we've already it's next year next year
the doors will break open next year next
year will grieve in the sky for
tomorrow's answer we're gonna fight
so here's to next year
[Music]
Carr the day seemed so slow
you can't let them is the worst will
pass over next day next year the world
will break up next to you in the sky
tomorrow
so he has to
[Music]
next year hugging and kissing every
single person I've ever loved in my
entire life next year everywhere in the
world next year and Jerusalem all of us
are going off
[Music]
next year we will be on vacation
good luck to Hawaii my friends with
friends and family shirt hi you copying
me next year in a more fair country next
year with our families I'm chosen next
year in a real democracy next year in a
theater with all of you I'm gonna say
next year I'm a boyfriend south looking
for a man a nice man next year
performing for everyone in the same room
next year with her grandparents next
year holding hands next year I want to
be surrounded by even more of my Jewish
brothers and sisters next year with hugs
and kisses with family next year in my
mom's kitchen in Long Island next year
by Lake Michigan and Chicago with my
family next year nice free drinking gin
and tonics next year in health at peace
with family at home
[Music]
how long you'll stay those early oceans
and deserts we've already crossed
goodnight everybody stay safe stay
healthy stay inside next year in
Jerusalem god bless
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the dog was angry with the cat for doing
such
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]